[Music]
what's my name what's my name Daniel my
name
[Music]
only three days to the world cotillion
how does it feel to be the most envied
girl in Oregon everybody wants me to be
this lady of the court and have no idea
how to keep up the act so don't you ever
miss screaming at people and just making
them run away from you not really
this isn't the Isle of the Lost now
believe me I know that it connects I'll
I'm back a little traitor who grabbed
everything she wanted it left me nothing
when I give my chance to random the evil
on Oregon how I'll take it this is my
fault
I should go there apologize just wait
until am ia sure back where's Ben not
captured him do you want Beastie Boy bad
bring me fairy godmothers magic one you
better hope your girlfriend comes
through
you always were quite the drama queen
this is between Emma and me we've been
through a lot together not stopping that
now you could stick a TR all new villain
but you still ability
you can't be
losing not an option because we're
rotten to the core take care by the way
I know I'm like loving it it's like a
long way hello
[Music]